in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Cheryl
is with us and her son David
hi Cheryl how are you hi babe welcome
welcome where do you live
Dayton Ohio fun welcome to Nashville
good to have you thank you
and you brought David with you always
David David 13 13 years old very cool
very cool well welcome it's so good to
have you thank you and you're here to do
your debt free for you yes how much have
you paid off fifty six thousand three
hundred and twenty dollars and 27 cents
I love it perfect and how long did that
take out thirty three months very good
making what kind of money started out at
69 for 42 and then Murphy hit and I
dropped down to 53 and now back up to
about 76 Wow what do you do for a living
I am a registered nurse good for you
okay very good
so how did Murphy hit if your registered
nurse well he had emergency surgery she
had to have a time off and then I had
surgery and the surgery went wrong and I
had have surgery again so I went into I
was on long-term disability and
short-term disability so it dropped my
income gotcha okay and obviously you're
a single mom
yes okay very cool so what kind of
deaths the fifty six thousand Oh Parent
PLUS loan Oh credit card so you got
another kid somewhere thank you for
calling
uh-huh okay how much a for Kali how much
was a fifty six was that about fifteen
thousand okay note to other single moms
out there if you're broke you can't
afford to sign for your kids college
loans man alright good so fifteen
thousand of the fifty six was that and
what's the rest of it a car loan credit
card medical bills house and pretty you
were just like normal
yes you've had everything yes good for
you like a regular American just do that
up your eyeballs right so what happened
thirty three months ago two and a half
plus years ago almost three years ago
actually it started before that I saw
you down at megafest in Atlanta few
years ago and that seed was planted and
then I had a card that was repossessed
and I was thinking if I owned this they
couldn't take it
mantasy was planet and then about 33
months ago I had started listening to
you on the radio and then I just started
believing that I could do it okay very
cool well we've always enjoyed doing
stuff with Bishop Jake's and Anthony
O'Neill one of our MC personalities
spoke down there to several thousand
people this just a few months back here
so at megafest so very very cool good
for you so what did you do what was the
process you said okay that's it I'm
listening on the radio and I'm going to
do what would you do I did a budget ah
the dreaded budget you were okay so I
did a budget and I I just start working
a lot of overtime okay worked a lot of
overtime just just a great place to go
when you're broke to work it's to work
bring in the extra money throw in about
the debt fast and what was the first
debt you paid off it was a small credit
card how'd that feel wonderful so it's
like this is gonna work mm-hmm a little
ding ding moment in your head right now
I felt like I can do this I can do this
and then I always listen to the debt
free screams that was a big motivator
for me yeah they're a big motivator for
me and I'm not even in debt so listening
to the radio and being on a budget you
just start plowing through this mm-hmm
all right if you have a copy of the
Total Money Makeover book yes very good
did you go through a financial fee I
didn't go through financial piece it's
not required it was curious what you did
okay very cool so did you have people
cheering for you or making fun of you or
both both okay both and what kind of
people made fun of you I wouldn't really
say made fun of me but kind of sort of
doubted your doubted ISM talked about me
working a lot cuz I worked a lot okay
you're not that isn't gonna make any
difference you're not gonna get anywhere
it's not gonna work you just work in
your view just you're working your life
away worked a lot yeah I hear ya that's
what they all say
when they're when they're negative yeah
and so 33 months later now that you're
on top of this mountain mm-hmm do you
remember when you were standing at the
bottom of the mountain
hmm was the climb harder or easier than
you thought it was going to be it was
harder harder than you thought it was it
was harder because like I said I had to
work a lot and and then the surgeries in
the end the time off and everything
right yeah I tripped you up but but one
good thing about even when I was off I
had started the process of getting out
of debt so a lot of the debts that I had
some of them I didn't have when I was
when he had surgery and then when I had
surgery so it was less of a strain and
it was less stressful with me being off
because I was already in the process so
you didn't lose as much ground right you
could see you could see the horse I just
got to get back on it yes yes very cool
good for you what do you tell people the
secret to getting out of debt is being
committed believing that you can do it
and staying focused I love it that's
perfect
I agree with it very very well done
Cheryl you're a rock star
thank you you rolled up your sleeves you
took control of your life you decided
what your destiny was gonna be you're
not a victim you told your life life I'm
gonna tell you what to do yeah and even
if you can knock me down I'm gonna get
back up I'm gonna tell you what to do
and very cool you're quite an example
for your son so David did you watch your
mom do all of this did you realize what
was going on yes
what did you notice most how much she
was working I bet I'll bet well maybe
she's back to more of a regular schedule
now so Cheryl how's it feel wonderful
I'm trying not to cry it just feels
wonderful I'm so proud of you so proud
of it congratulate thank you you met you
you have the ability to make you know 70
80 thousand dollars and you don't have a
payment in the world you could really
build some pretty serious wealth you
really can completely change your family
tree now you've set yourself in position
to do that that's pretty amazing thank
all the way from a Parent PLUS loan to
being a millionaire someday
yes that's my go I think I think you're
on your way I think you're on your way
all right well let's count it down David
and Cheryl Dayton Ohio
$56,000 paid off in 33 months making 69
then down to 53 then up to 76 count it
down
let's hear a debt free
Green three two one you did it I love it
rock star man I love it I love it I love
it very very very well done
you